hi there guys Lucy here with a quick
GSU's update for you sony computer
entertainment japan has held its pre
Tokyo Game Show press conference here's
the highlights it may have been leaked
last week on xbox calm but now we've got
official confirmation that resident evil
revelations to exist Capcom took to the
stage to reveal that the sequel to the
2012 survival horror game is coming in
2015 revelations 2 will be cross-gen
launching on ps3 ps4 xbox 360 xbox one
and pc but there's no release insight
for any nintendo consoles which is
strange as the original was a 3 dias
exclusive before being ported to last
gen consoles a year later next up gothic
RPG blood-borne has been given a release
date well for Japan at least the souls
Ian PlayStation 4 exclusive will launch
on februari 5th 2015 it's currently
being developed by from software and
Sony's Japan studio with demon Falls and
Dark Souls lead hit attacker Miyazaki
directing and it's time to go back to
school atlas and Sony have announced
that JRPG meets waifu simulator persona
5 will be coming to PlayStation 4 in
2015 while there's no word on an exact
release date yet atlas has teased us
with some new cut scene footage the
highly anticipated sequel to 2008
persona 4 was originally announced as a
ps3 exclusive back in November and
finally Sony have announced new
customization options for the
PlayStation 4 and the Vita when firmware
to point out launches you'll be able to
install custom themes on both machines
so what were your highlights from Sony's
awesome press conference you're excited
for any of the titles are you ready to
pimp your PlayStation let me know in the
comments for the latest gaming teenage
melodrama stay tuned here to gamespot
you